[Music]
this morning on the dish gage and toner
and to put things into perspective
that's a restaurant's name whose diners
were already familiar with it back in
the late 1800s the eatery was an
institution in brooklyn new york for
well over a century pre-dating the
brooklyn bridge the statue of liberty
and even the city subway system it's
seen plenty of ups and downs including
two worldwide pandemics and it's our
current one that delayed its much
anticipated reopening almost two years
ago but now it's back in business once
again
the new restaurant in town has a line
out the door
with people angling for the raw bar
vintage cocktails and the old world
atmosphere on the back 31 porter 31 rib
spinach mashed fries and sprouts the
food in chef adam shepherd's kitchen is
reeling them in too strip
crab cake onion rings
what do you mean
it's the long story exactly what long
time friends and owners sinchin frizzell
ben schneider and zoe kim had hoped for
when he shared a meal before the
official re-opening of gage and told us
this is gorgeous all of this describe
what we're seeing in front of us all
right we have a classic caesar salad
right here this is our steak aged 28
days this is our house made parker house
rolls a classic wedge salad classic very
classic okay another classic staple here
cream spinach
they were celebrating the rebirth of a
brooklyn landmark that it shuttered 17
years ago it was like heartbreaking for
the borough and i think there's a lot of
civic
pride involved in the reopening and it's
not about the three of us it's about
this beautiful
place you know getting the doors back
open here it's like reopening a library
or something it's like public
institution
opened in
1879 charles gage and eugene tolner
moved their restaurant to this fulton
street location in 1892 and for 125
years it stayed true to its oyster chop
house roots even as it passed through
multiple sets of owners and chefs
including culinary legend edna lewis but
in 2004 all of that came to an end do
you know why it closed the dining
patterns were changing in brooklyn it
was a little bit of a ghost town down
here that's when frizzell discovered it
it was sort of hidden away
boarded up what made you spy on it the
last time we knew about this place it
was a clothing store you couldn't see
the walls you couldn't really see the
chandeliers but he could see the
potential an historic space he hoped to
buy with the owners of another brooklyn
eatery the good fork i found out one of
the former owners was a regular customer
of mine at the good fork and i called
him up he advised me against it why for
good reason i was too young i didn't
know i wasn't ready a decade would go by
before the time was finally right i
think a lot of people are very nostalgic
the fact that a lot of old institutions
are closing and for us the way that we
found this place it was perfectly
preserved because it was landmarked
landmarked in 1975
the third interior landmark next to
grant's tomb and public library start
rolling schneider took on the
restoration from its original revolving
door to the once gas-powered lamps we
had to of course clean them up and make
them glow were there any surprises and
then we found hatch door at the very top
of the building i opened it up and then
in there was a whole bunch of this
historical stuff that we found old menus
for me it was actually looking at all
these old menus from a kitchen
standpoint and or looking at a menu that
would represent gage and toner in the
21st century it was
so exciting to look back at the i don't
know the oldest menu going back to
19 yeah 19 19 19.
but three days after this lunch
interview the pandemics shut down nyc
and much of the world
for that entire year i've been wondering
are they coming back did that thought
ever we were wondering too
i knew we would figure out a way i mean
you can't come that far and then not
somehow make it
and a year later one of new york's
oldest continuously run restaurants made
the comeback of comebacks
this moment has to be a great exhale
yeah oh yeah how good does this feel it
feels great when we opened again we were
open at 50
and no seating at the bar and all the
servers and masks but it was like
magical and it's been magical ever since
the resurrection here also gave life to
the sunken harbor club
an upscale speakeasy just upstairs
literally every day we're talking to
people that used to eat here and have
fun memories of the place and them
saying
this is better than we
remembered it thank you so much for not
letting this one go next hands are
coming up to the window right now chef
and that includes the owner that tried
to talk them out of it
and he said
nicely done
did he really he's been a big supporter
yeah i think he's proud of us now we
just got to get brock and michelle to
come
[Laughter]
so great to have you back here
thank you for coming